[Musique]
à la une les alpes-maritimes fixé ce
soir confinement localiser ou pas le
préfet doit rendre sa décision au
lendemain d'une visite du ministre de la
santé olive et veyran à nice où le maire
demande aux touristes de ne pas venir
dans la région le département et dans le
rouge le taux d'incidence du variant
britannique est très ému
le second tour de la présidentielle au
niger la fermeture des bureaux de vote
et proche de 4 millions d'électeurs
appelés aux urnes
la fiche le candidat du parti au pouvoir
mohamed bazoum vainqueur au premier tour
et mahamane ousmane l'ex chef de l'état
de ce [ __ ] est synonyme de première
transition démocratique dans l'histoire
du pays
après deux mandats de mahamadou issoufou
[Musique]
et puis en birmanie une journée
d'émotion le pays a rendu hommage à la
première victime de la répression
militaire qui a fait deux morts et une
trentaine de blessés hier une épicière
de 20 ans blessé par balle deux filles
elle est morte vendredi elle est devenue
le symbole de la lutte contre la junte
qui a renversé au food succi il ya trois
semaines
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue si vous nous
rejoignez sur arte france le département
à des alpes maritimes sera fixé sur son
sort ce soir le préfet doit statuer sur
un possible confinement locale le
département est confrontée à une
circulation active des variantes du
colis de 19 à nice le taux d'incidence
dépasse 700 pour 100000 habitants très
loin devant la moyenne nationale aux
côtés d'olivier ferrand le ministre de
la santé en visite à nice hier le maire
de l'est républicain de la ville
christian estrosi s'est dit favorable à
un renforcement des mesures sanitaires
et il l'a rappelé encore ce matin chez
nos confrères de france info
je suis rassuré qu olivier ferrand et
dit qu'il y aurait une décision dès ce
soir
naturellement il ne faut pas une mise
sous cloche mais la ligne de crête la
plus efficace
l'accélération de la vaccination nous
paraît essentiel
ce que je sais c'est qu'il faut prendre
une décision une mesure fort pour aller
au delà de la mesure générale prise pour
toute la france est la moselle est
également concernée par la circulation
inquiétant des variants d'ailleurs
l'allemagne envisage de durcir ses
mesures de précaution anvers
départements du grand est
le gouvernement allemand pourrait exiger
des tests négatifs datant de 48 heures
maximum pour toute personne en
provenance de la moselle
l'exécutif allemand se réunit demain
autour de ce dossier chien
il y avait cet après midi un
rassemblement place de la république à à
part ils sont nombreux à s'être réunis à
la veille de deux ans du iracà
rassemblement de soutien à ce mouvement
de contestation né le 22 février 2019 en
algérie notre reporter thomas bonnet
était sur place
plusieurs milliers de manifestants
rassemblés ce dimanche après midi sur la
place de la république à paris une
manifestation qui initialement devait se
rendre en direction de la place de la
nation et finalement les organisateurs
ont annoncé dans le courant de l'après
midi que la préfecture de police de
paris n'autorisait pas cette
manifestation à se déplacer alors
certains ont tout de même tenté de s'y
rendre ils en ont été empêchés par les
gendarmes mais aussi par d'autres
manifestants qui me voulait absolument
pas voir de débordements lors de cette
manifestation qui se veut pacifique
rassemblement pour marquer le deuxième
anniversaire du mouvement de
contestation populaire né le 22 février
2019 en algérie qui était né à l'époque
suite à l'annoncé du président abdelaziz
bouteflika de sa volonté de briguer un
nouveau mandat finalement le mouvement
de contestation s'était étendue dans
tout le pays avait conduit le président
bouteflika quitter le pouvoir mais
depuis tout n'est pas réglé en algérie
c'est ce que nous explique les
manifestants ici qui réclame un
changement plus large un changement de
système propose d'écouter quelques unes
de leurs revendications au micro de
didier mulot je tiens
abily cité le peuple algérien pour sa
résistance contre ce pouvoir totalitaire
qui veut nous empêcher de bâtir notre
état de droit c'est pour continuer avec
la communauté algérienne à paris et les
amis de l'algérie parce qu'il n'ya pas
que les algériens qui militent et qui
souhaite la démocratie en algérie
c'est donc pour être avec eux il s'agit
aujourd'hui d'arracher la souveraineté
pleine et entière du peuple algérien
donc la révolution du peuple algérien
pour la démocratie pour sa souveraineté
a commencé depuis très longtemps mais il
ya eu une étape qui a été le 22 février
et là c'est une autre étape une volonté
de changement qu'ils expriment donc ici
à paris mais aussi en algérie des
rassemblements sont prévus ces prochains
jours pour marquer le deuxième
anniversaire du irak beaucoup d'appels à
manifester ont été lancés notamment sur
les réseaux sociaux et puis parmi les
revendications qui circulent ici dans
les rangs des manifestants il ya sel il
s'adresse directement au pouvoir des
gouvernements occidentaux il reproche
par exemple à la france est donc à
emmanuel macron une forme de complicité
avec le pouvoir algérien en place un
pouvoir dont vous l'aurez compris il ne
veulent absolument plus entendre parler
ils veulent un réel changement de
système un changement au sens large
et puis un autre rassemblement cette
fois en faveur de la pma devant
l'assemblée nationale des dizaines de
personnes venues exprimer leur désaccord
après que le sénat a amendé le projet de
loi bioéthique tel qu'il avait été voté
par l'assemblée nationale c'était l'été
dernier les manifestants souhaitent un
élargissement de la loi notamment en
faveur des homosexuels et des femmes
célibataires un projet initialement
promis par emmanuel macron écouter ces
ragots dans les derniers
ben ça a été très occupés par des
personnes se disant avec des valeurs de
la famille donc j'ai pas envie de nommer
ici mais qui qui ne nous écoute pas et
qui nous crache dessus d'une violence
inouïe contre nous alors qu'on nous
n'allons pas contre leur propre droit
est juste on voulait dire qu'en fatigue
on n'existe pas ici en tant que l entité
politique en tant qu'individu avec
l'histoire bien personnel on n'est plus
dans une france où on a des enfants à 20
ans marie y en a des enfants en fait le
couple maintenant ses formes diverses
on peut aussi avoir envie d'avoir des
enfants sans forcer l'entrée au couple
donc voilà si je trouve ça juste un peu
dommage que ça soit que la jeunesse
on va dire qu'il soit la présence je
pense que les parents des gens qui sont
là sont autant concernés que les enfants
et human et s'ensuit stérile et j'aime
les femmes donc pour moi avoir un enfant
mais mettant est heureux c'est déjà
compliqué et si en plus on retire le
droit d'avoir un enfant avec une autre
femme
étant moi-même stérile ça me retirer
toutes les chances d'avoir un enfant
plus tard et c'est vachement égoïste
quand même surtout moi qui aurais jamais
d'enfant en fait si on part de ce
principe là je pourrais pas avoir
d'enfant que mon orientation je ferai
pas avoir d'enfant si je vais emporter
[Musique]
israël allège aujourd'hui certaines à 2
ces restrictions sanitaires commerces de
rue centres commerciaux marché musées
librairies rouvrent leurs portes les
restaurants et les bars doivent attendre
jusqu'au 7 mars au moins la situation
sanitaire en voie d'amélioration dans le
pays où un pass vert à téléchargeable
dans les prochains jours va permettre
l'accès aux salles de sport aux hôtels
aux piscines et au spectacle et cela des
personnes ayant reçu deux doses de
vaccin en écoute
les dernières déclarations du premier
ministre benyamin nétanyahou qui sera
dans le commerce elle nous ne pouvons
malheureusement pas faire un badge vert
car il ya des services essentiels comme
les cliniques dans les centres
commerciaux les médecins les pharmacies
la nourriture
donc nous ne pouvons pas faire un badge
vers nous le faisons par étapes
toute personne qui a le label vert peut
profiter des salles de sport bientôt des
restaurants des cinémas des vols toutes
ces choses vous seront donnés mais nous
le faisons avec soin des discussions
fructueuses entre l'iran et le chef de
l' agence internationale de l'énergie
atomique raf est grossi en déplacement à
teyran der en a qui s'en est d'ailleurs
fourni cité à deux jours de la mise en
place de la mise en application prévue
d'une loi qui limiterait les inspections
des activités nucléaires en cas de
maintien des sanctions américaines et
une conférence de presse doit être
organisée ce soir après le retour du
chef de l'aiea à vienne a pour karim
pakzad chercheur associé à l'iris et
spécialiste de l'iran malgré la bonne
volonté affichée ces derniers jours le
dossier reste encore très sensible mais
le problème nico même si ces disques
social s'engage disette des états unis
ne sont toujours pas membre
dodd de cet accord et surtout les
iraniennes
il entra dans six coups ils sont
d'accord à se coller les américains bien
discuter mais à titre d'invité tantôt
les amalgames empalot et la totalité des
sanctions iranien contre l'irlande dire
on n'accepterait pas à ce que les
américains road oriane le membre à part
entière de l'accord sur le nucléaire
donc on est quand même loin encore d'une
solution définitive
en équateur le second tour de l'élection
présidentielle est prévue le 11 avril
prochain le conseil national équatorien
a annoncé les résultats officiels du
premier tour après deux semaines
d'attentes
l économiste andres arros c'est de
placer en tête avec presque 33 % des
voix soutenue par l'ancien président
rafael correa face à lui donc gear
mollet faut le conservateur et ex
banquier qui a récolté presque 20% des
voix lui est accusé de fraude par le
leader indigène yacou perez qui a fini
en troisième position à l'issue du
premier tour
un scrutin encore très incertain selon à
julian call fuir secrétaire national du
parti de gauche est responsable
international des jeunes insoumis s'est
rendu en en équateur en tant
qu'observateur de cette élection écouter
siens tout le problème qu'on a eu en
tant qu observateurs internationaux en
arrivant sur place allaient
effectivement de constater beaucoup de
tension dans le pays du fait de
l'organisation des élections par le
conseil national électoral qui étaient
treize remise en cause notamment de la
part des choristes et la gauche en
général c'est tout l'intérêt du cookie
et beaucoup d'observateurs
internationaux pour garantir le respect
de la démocratie et du processus
électoral du premier tour et tout le
problème qu'on a aujourd'hui c'est qu'on
a une incertitude totale sur le le
devenir du second tour comment va-t-il
se passer quand va-t-il se dérouler
alors effectivement il a contextes
locaux vides mais il y as qui est le
gars le second qui en face dahra aux
puisqu'on sait que c'est lui qui est
arrivé
le candidat de la gauche de gorée lb
correa est arrivé 1er mai qui est le
second est ce seuil à coup perez et
guillermo olaso on ne sait toujours pas
les résultats officiels n'ont toujours
pas été dévoilés il ya un recomptage qui
est prévue en comptage qui va durer
encore plusieurs plusieurs semaines donc
on voit que le actuellement le processus
électoral est comment dire est assez
pourri par par plusieurs affaires par
plusieurs intérêts qui sont très
différents qui vont être déjà été
révélée récemment au sein du conseil
électoral
et ça ne l'a être prêt pour le moment
rien présager de bon pour la tenue du
second tour donc il ya encore une grosse
incertitude et le second tour de
l'élection présidentielle au niger libye
de vote ont fermé vont fermer bientôt
leurs portes fait millions quatre cent
mille électeurs appelés aux urnes un
scrutin qui oppose mohamed bazoum le
candidat du parti au pouvoir donné
favori à mahamane ousmane l'ex président
du pays un scrutin à dans un climat
sécuritaire tendu mais qui pourraient
aboutir à une transition pacifique
inédite et au congo le niger face à son
destin
après deux mandats du président sortant
mamadou issoufou le pays peut être gay à
la première transition démocratique de
son histoire
ce second tour verra s'opposer le
candidat du parti au pouvoir mohamed
bazoum arrivé en tête avec 39% des voix
à mamane ousmane président du niger de
1993 à 1996 dans ce territoire enclavé
au coeur du sahel qui a subi de nombreux
coups d'état
l'espoir est immense près de deux mois
après le premier tour
la commission électorale du pays se veut
confiante sur la bonne organisation du
scrutin
la race ont le ventre et les autorités
pour vos niveaux et les autorités rossi
de la ceni ont pris toutes les
dispositions je dis bien toutes les
dispositions pour que tous ces donneurs
normalement en tout cas dans l'intérêt
de tous une élection qui se déroule sous
haute tension
le pays est en proie depuis plusieurs
années à des attaques de groupes
djihadistes affiliés à des ch et à boko
haram
des milliers de soldats ont été déployés
pour sécuriser le scrutin
des précautions qui n'empêche pas
l'inquiétude d'une partie de la
population écologistes
c'est ça mais pour les grands problèmes
vraiment en sécurité
nous ce qu'on attend des élections c'est
que ça c'est pas à bord de l'appliquer
transparence avec
pour assez convaincant des électeurs et
tout le monde participe
il est massif tous les nigériens
un vote qui se déroulera sous la
supervision de dizaines d'observateurs
de la communauté économique d'afrique de
l'ouest
en cas de succès de l'élection et
d'acceptation du résultat par
l'opposition le défi du futur président
sera immense
objectif principal accélérer le
développement du pays
classé dernier au monde sur l' indice de
développement humain établi par le
programme des nations unies pour le
développement
et puis sachez que sept membres locaux
de la commission électorale nationale
indépendante ont été tués lors de
l'explosion de leur véhicule qui a roulé
sur une mine
il s'agit de président le bureau de vote
et de leur secrétaire selon le
gouverneur de la région de tillabéri où
s'est produit le drame
le président sortant du niger mahamadou
issoufou a salué lui le second tour de
cette présidentielle il a renoncé en
rappel à se présenter après deux mandats
on écoute le peuple
l'alternance pacifique qui a manqué au
niger depuis deux décennies va se
réaliser
je suis fier
je suis fier d'être le premier président
démocratiquement élu de notre histoire à
pouvoir passer le relais à notre
président démocratiquement élu
c'est un événement majeur de la vie
politique et les deux candidats en lice
aujourd'hui se connaissent bien écouter
aboubakar à barbe il est le rédacteur en
chef du média tunisien
ces deux candidats qu'ils s'assoient
ousmane et bazou sont de la même
génération si c'est qu'on appelle ici la
génération post démocratique c'est à
dire ils ont fait leur apparition sur la
scène politique à partir des années 90
notamment au lendemain de la conférence
nationale qui a suivi le discours de la
baule de la phrase qui a suivi la
conférence nationale lorsque le niger a
instauré la démocratie et le
multipartisme en 1990 pour la petite
histoire lorsque baron haussmann le
congrès l'opposition aujourd'hui a été
élu le premier président
démocratiquement élu utilisèrent en 93
c'était avec le soutien du pnds de
mahamadou issoufou mettant son
gouvernement
il y avait besoin de mettre donc c'est
des gens qui se connaissent qui sont de
la même génération
depuis 98 30 ans soit son allié soit il
son opposant c'est ce qu'on appelle ici
les vieux loups de la politique
nigérienne pas de l'ère post
démocratique donc même si c'est un
changement de programme c'est un
changement de gouvernance mais les deux
ce qui sont de la même mouture de la
même génération démocratique au niger et
en république démocratique du congo un
peu plus de deux mois après la fin de la
coalition avec le front commun pour le
congo le chef de l'état félicité 10 ha
ha nommé en début de semaine à un
nouveau premier ministre pour son
gouvernement
elle les attentes sont nombreuses avant
l' annonce de la prochaine équipe
ministérielle
et qui devra plancher sur la situation
sécuritaire et la lutte contre le
chômage on voit cela avec l'audi
murhabazi et nicolas petit tout le monde
attend le nouveau gouvernement au
tournant de la société civile jusqu aux
acteurs politiques au sein des
parlementaires les attentes concernent
notamment les problèmes liés à
l'insécurité et aux groupes armées de la
république démocratique du congo
les gonzes armés ont commencé à être
démobilisé il ya beaucoup de des jeunes
qui ont commencé à quitter le port
d'armé mais ce qui n'a pas suivi c'est
la mise en place de la structure devant
encadrer ces jeunes là et là on a
constaté que un problème défense est
posée voilà pourquoi nous avons salué l'
la décision du chef de l'état lorsqu'il
a décidé de mettre sur pied l'union
sacrée pour la nation parce que nous
estimons que c'est une vision qui va
permettre de matérialiser cette vision
de la réduction ou les indications de
cours armés d'après l'onu en république
démocratique du congo
plus de 2000 personnes ont été tuées au
cours de l'année 2020 dans des attaques
attribuées à la milice islamiste des
forces démocratiques alliées et d'autres
groupes armés des millions de déplacés
internes ont aussi été enregistrés dans
l'est du pays
le mouvement citoyen lutte pour le
changement espère que ce nouveau
gouvernement d'union sacrée saura se
démarquer de la précédente équipe
dirigée par sylvestre longa lukamba les
bilans du précédent gouvernement est
calamiteux peut-être lé bilan est
positif dans les reproches et dans le
ventre mais pour le panier de la
ménagère pour la sécurité c'est
catastrophique en république
démocratique du congo
elle a des cultures constitue une
activité économique majeure mais dans la
plupart des provinces les routes sont
occupées par les rebelles ou en état de
délabrement avancé
la société civile espère donc du
prochain gouvernement
la réouverture de ces voies de desserte
agricole et la promotion de l'emploi des
jeunes nous ne sommes pas satisfaits de
l'état de nos routes de desserte
agricole
regardez pour quitter masisi les
produits agricoles pourrissent en août
c'est la rupture nous arriver ici en
ville avec un immense retard il un bon
cru de denrées à cause de l'insécurité
et du délabrement telle route audio ping
nous commençons à dépendre des pays
voisins pour nous ravitailler en
produits de première nécessité c'est
déplorable
j'aimerais que le prochain gouvernement
incarne le changement et fasse ce que le
précédent n'a pas été en mesure de faire
premièrement nous les jeunes qui avons
un peu étudiée ils doivent d'abord nous
donnons de l'emploi et là on saura que
le gouvernement fait bien son travail
aujourd'hui je me débrouille pour
survivre alors le nouveau gouvernement
doit trouver des moyens et recettes
nécessaires pour que les jeunes
travaillent
c'est aussi simple que ça dans sa
première prise de parole l'ex ministre
des sports du président kabila et
nouveau chef du gouvernement a annoncé
dans un premier temps une équipe
ministérielle réduite la précédente
comporter 65 membres avec des dépenses
considérables qui ont handicapé le
trésor public
bien sûr nous allons revenir avec des
chiffres beaucoup plus précis en terme
de
le nombre de ministres de vice ministère
mais ça sera certainement moins que la
taille du gouvernement actuel pour le
reste nous allons nous mettre le plus
tôt en contact avec l'informateur qui va
nous donner les résultats des travaux
qu'il a fait parce que ça nous donne les
forces politiques en présence et ça va
nous permettre de discuter avec les
différents responsables
pour rappel le désormais ex premiers
ministres sylvestre lunga look en bas a
dû démissionner le 29 janvier dernier
après avoir été destitué par l'assemblée
nationale deux jours plus tôt une
décision faisant suite à la volonté du
président tshisekedi de changer la
majorité parlementaire en sa faveur
le nouveau gouvernement devrait être
investi lors de la session parlementaire
du mois de mars prochain en birmanie les
motions dans le pays les funérailles de
mme il ya une jeune épicière de 20 ans
devenu l'icône de la résistance
entre larmes et trois semaines après le
coup de force des militaires
la répression contre les manifestants
continuent résultat deux morts et une
trentaine de blessés hier le point
vainqueur grégoire dofus
la tension monte d'un cran en birmanie
dans les rues de mende à l'oeil la
deuxième ville du pays
les tirs des forces de sécurité envers
les manifestants ont eu des conséquences
dramatiques
bilan deux morts et une trentaine de
blessés ils ont battu et tué mon mari et
d'autres personnes il se tenait à côté
et regarder la manifestation mais les
soldats l'ont emmené des violences
immédiatement qualifiée d'inacceptable
par une partie de la communauté
internationale
je condamne fermement la violence contre
des manifestants civils pacifiques par
les militaires j'exhorte l'armée et
toutes les forces de sécurité en
birmanie à mettre fin immédiatement aux
violences contre les civils
nous discuterons lundi des derniers
événements birmanie pour prendre les
décisions appropriées
je condamne le recours à la violence
mortelle en birmanie le recours à la
force meurtrière à l'intimidation et au
harcèlement contre des manifestants
pacifiques est inacceptable
tout le monde a le droit de se réunir
pacifiquement j'appelle toutes les
parties à respecter les résultats des
élections et à revenir à un régime civil
depuis le 1er février et le coup d'état
militaire contre le gouvernement donc
sotchi
la vague de contestation se poursuit
malgré la répression ils étaient ce
samedi encore des milliers dans les rues
de rangoon la capitale économique du
pays
les militaires ont déclaré qu'il
gouvernait de manière démocratique mais
en même temps ils ont immédiatement
coupé la connexion internet est bloqué
les réseaux sociaux comme facebook et
twitter c'est signifie que leurs paroles
ne correspondent pas à leurs actes donc
on ne les croira jamais si locale
on ne peut pas accepter la répression
policière parce qu'elle est indiscipliné
au delà des lois
je suis vraiment désolé de voir que
certains manifestants ont été attaqués
même s'ils ne sont pas de ma famille
malgré les multiples condamnations de la
communauté internationale et de
plusieurs ong
le pouvoir militaire reste pour le
moment sourd aux appels à la désescalade
une nouvelle ère commence pour des
milliers d'émigrants un premier groupe
de demandeurs d'asile a traversé la
frontière américaine vendredi sept
derniers sont satisfaits de la nouvelle
politique migratoire des états unis
impulsée par joe biden politique qui se
lèvent tous des inquiétudes concernant
la rapidité des futurs traitement des
candidatures
le président mexicain demandent
davantage de visas spéciaux pour ces
travailleurs migrants walid bennani l
inquiétude de nelly maribel cabreira un
dernier coup de téléphone avant une
délivrance
oui je suis un peu excité vous savez
parce que nous avons entendu une
nouvelle que le nouveau président a
donné l'autorisation d'ouvrir les
tribunaux ce vendredi et c'est mon tour
d'aller au tribunal et j'en suis un peu
heureuse une attente longue de quatre
mois pour être ensuite transférés et
placé en quarantaine dans un hôtel de
san diego
avant d'être hébergé chez un parent des
milliers de demandeurs d'asile provenant
d'amérique centrale
heureux désormais d'abord l'occasion
d'attendre sur le territoire américain
le temps que leur dossier soit instruit
lorsqu'ils s'inscrivent ils reçoivent un
appel avec plus d'informations
ils doivent passer un test qu'aux vide
ils doivent être approuvées par le
service des douanes et de la protection
des frontières des états unis tout le
monde recevra un rendez vous pour se
présenter
ils ne seront pas traités sans rendez
vous ils commenceront avec 25 personnes
par jour et passeront à 300 personnes
par jour traitées ici au poste d'entrée
rester au mexique programmes lancés sous
la présidence de donald trump est
désavoué par son successeur joe biden
depuis plus de deux ans environ soixante
dix mille personnes ont déposé une
candidature dans le cadre de ce
programme controversé une grande partie
obligé donc d'attendre sur le sol
mexicain avant que leur demande soit
traitée aujourd'hui joe biden change de
cap et a décidé d'arrêter la
construction d'un mur à la frontière
mexique etats unis une décision saluée
par le président mexicain qui réclame
encore plus de considération pour des
migrants décrit comme une force vitale
pour l'économie américaine
quelle est la force de travail du
mexique et de l'amérique centrale est
nécessaire aux états-unis joe médicaux
ainsi au lieu de l'immigration
clandestine comme c'est le cas
actuellement on peut trouver un
mécanisme de délivrance de visas pour
les travailleurs des délices
satisfaction aujourd'hui mais beaucoup
d'interrogations demain autour des
demandeurs d'asile provenant d'amérique
centrale et retourne et non pas au
mexique mais dans leur pays en raison
des réformes de donald trump
les responsables des nations unies ont
demandé aux migrants de ne pas se
précipiter à la frontière américano
mexicaine et c'est la fin de ce journal
merci à vous de l'avoir suivi on va se
retrouver tout à l'heure dans 30 minutes
rester avec nous sur air france
[Musique]
vous insistez beaucoup sur l'aspect des
dépenses publiques ce que je critique
c'est que on est dans un état
d'addiction de grande dépendance à la
dépense publique je ne veux pas du sang
et des larmes le son et les dames on les
a déjà trop de dépenses trop d'état je
pense en tout cas qu'il ya trop de
bureaucratie c'est à dire un état
inefficace tout ça a été financée
essentiellement par de la dette
le problème est moins la dette en
réalité moi je pense qu'on remboursera
la dette par la croissance donc il